now let's get a little bit more on that
to 20 meter sinkhole which has opened up
on a residential street instant albans I
mean they're the latest pictures from
the air they are extraordinary that this
sinkhole has as you can imagine it
they've forced the evacuation of of some
families in the area it spreads as you
can see across a driveway and a front
garden of a property and it's ten meters
deep as we say 20 meters wide and also
one of the results of the sinkhole is
that more than 50 properties are now
without gas and electricity at the fire
service have said they were already
aware of a small hole which was due to
be filled in but then received a call to
say dad opened up substantially
overnight and substantially as the word
isn't it so obviously a lot of questions
for the owners of that property and for
people generally in the area I guess but
it's not the first time we've seen
sinkholes just in the last year there
was one in Manchester City Center in
August and February early this year
there was one in Hartford sure a garden
another area of Hartford shear near
Watford and in the same month a house in
Ripon in North Yorkshire too so
sinkholes clearly a little bit of an
issue we'll be discussing them a little
bit later